fue en el vídeo pasado donde analizamos
las raíces de mi ecuación característica
la cual está asociada a mi ecuación de
segundo orden y las raíces eran reales
entonces la solución tomaba esta forma
de aquí sin embargo teníamos que
resolverlo con las condiciones iniciales
para obtener la segundo y la c2 ahora
bien si lo que queremos es que las
raíces sean complejas es decir de
cuadrada menos 4 ac es negativo entonces
las raíces van a ser complejas y con
jugadas y entonces les pusimos el nombre
de las raíces de lambda más o menos mío
y donde el hambre me eran reales
en fin hicimos un buen de álgebra en el
vídeo pasado pasamos unas cosas de un
lado las otras cosas del otro lado y
podemos factorizar un e a la lambda x
este al alhambra x multiplicaba
alamí x y más o menos mil x xi y
entonces fue aquí donde utilizamos la
fórmula de hoy de nuestra fórmula de
wyler que decía que x es igual a coste
de x más veces seno de x y entonces
utilizando la identidad de oler
sustituyamos y cada vez que pedíamos
al amigo x y pues poníamos coseno de mil
x más veces seno de x por la fórmula de
hoy leer y cada vez que veíamos a la
menos x y entonces poníamos coseno de
menos x más y veces se nos dé menos mi x
pero ahora voy a utilizar cosas que
nosotros hemos visto en trigonometría es
muy importante que ustedes se acuerdan
de esto primero el consejo de menos teta
es igual al coste no de teta y segundo
que el seno de menos teta es igual a
menos el seno de teta que quiere decir
esto pues que cosenos una función par y
el pse no es una función impar si
utilizamos esto en nuestra solución
general entonces vamos a obtener lo
siguiente
que es igual a ala blanda x por lo que
tenemos aquí y ahora voy a distribuir la
constante 1 me va a quedar la constante
1 que multiplica al coseno de mx más y
veces la constante 1 ojos estoy
distribuyendo la constante 1 por el seno
de mi x
bien y ahora esto lo voy a tener que
agregar lado el otro sumando entonces
distribuir también las dos las de todos
está multiplicando al coseno de menos
mío x pero utilizando lo que ya sabíamos
que es una función para entonces me va a
quedar que es el coseno de mil x ojos se
va al menos porque mi función es par más
veces la constante dos por el seno de
menos mil x pero el seno de menos x es
negativo entonces puede borrar esto de
aquí y le voy a poner sino de menos me
va a quedar el seno de mil x ojo porque
el seno era una función impar y esto lo
vamos a utilizar debido a que vamos a
factorizar el coseno de mi x y el seno
de mi x observe muy bien la solución
general ya casi la tenemos por completo
lo que voy a hacer es primero pues poner
al alhambra x s adelante x se mantiene
ahí y nos movemos nada
pero lo que voy a hacer ahora es fijarme
en el core seno de mi x fíjense que el
coseno dmx aparece aquí y acá es decir
está multiplicando a una constante 1 y
en la constante 2 vamos a actualizar el
proceso de mx y ahorita ustedes se van a
dar cuenta a qué me refiero con que esto
nos va a servir y ahora fijémonos lo
mismo para el seno de mi b x aparece
tanto aquí como acá es decir es la
constante 1 x y menos aquellos 9 menos y
veces la constante 2 ok y esto está
multiplicado por el seno de mil x los
factores pero la razón por la que lo
estoy factor izando es que tanto se 1
como c 2 son constantes arbitrarias
entonces yo no me voy a complicar la
vida y voy a decir que sea uno más de
dos es otra constante pongamos la esa
nueva constante cts porque le pongo se
tres pues para no cargar todo el tiempo
con c1 c2 es más práctico decirse tres
si se 1 s 2 son dos constantes pues se 3
es otro también no hay problema
y ahora voy a hacer lo mismo con c1 y c2
y la voy a llamar una nueva constante
una constante s 4 observen que ese 1 y c
2 y pues puede ser real puede ser
imaginario no lo sabemos pero lo que sí
estoy seguro es que se uno y marce todos
y es otra constante cualquier constante
entonces lo voy a llamar esta constante
c4
esto nos da pie a que ya por fin podamos
escribir completamente la solución
general en lugar de estar cargando con
c1 y c2 y c3 y no voy a estar cargando
con c1 y c2 y ya posee ese 4 y entonces
le voy a poner otro color
la solución general me va a quedar el
alambre x que multiplica a una constante
vamos a ponerle ese 3 por el coseno de
1000 x
más
otra constante vamos a ponerle ese 4
ustedes pueden ponerle el nombre que
quieran pero esta constante va a
multiplicar al seno de mi x y que creen
aquí está ya por fin la solución general
de mi problema cuando tenemos raíces
complejas
qué bonito ejercicio a mí me gusta mucho
pero me voy a regresar un poco para que
veamos qué pasó y de donde se formó todo
esto nosotros nos basamos en la ecuación
general de las raíces reales fue aquí
donde sustituimos a nuestras raíces
complejas y fue cuando utilizamos un
poquito de álgebra pusimos algunas
constantes por aquí lambda x por acá
distribuimos a x usamos la fórmula de
oier utilizamos que el cosenos parqué el
seno sin par factor hicimos algunas
constantes y con todo esto obtuvimos la
solución general de las raíces que son
de la forma ni más menos new no
y uno no habíamos dicho que eran lambda
perdón más o menos mí y donde el ámbar y
muse son reales y con esto obteníamos
así la solución general para las raíces
complejas y yo sé que ustedes me van a
decir que tal vez a aprenderse todo este
procedimiento sea un poco complicado tal
vez en un examen ustedes tengan que
aplicarlo de una manera más rápida en
lugar de hacer todos la talacha y
acordarse de todas estas cosas pero
también es muy importante que al menos
una vez en la vida resolvamos todas la
teoría para saber de dónde salen
nuestros procedimientos vuelvo a lo
mismo si ustedes lo que necesitan es
obtener el resultado de una manera mucho
más rápido
es muy fácil aprenderse que la solución
general tiene esta forma el ala lambda x
es decir el elevado a la parte real por
equis que multiplica a una constante por
el coseno de 1000 x es decir por el
coste no de la parte imaginaria por x
otra constante por el seno de mi x es
decir por la parte imaginaria por equis
bien pues obteniendo todo esto que hemos
hecho en estos vídeos voy a resolver un
ejercicio para que vean de una manera
rápida cómo lo podemos resolver la
ecuación va a ser de mi prima más prima
más de todo esto igual a cero y por lo
tanto mi ecuación característica va a
ser re cuadrada más cr más uno igual a
cero pero como es una fórmula general
pues saquemos sus raíces me va a quedar
menos b pero es uno entonces me queda
menos uno más menos la raíz cuadrada de
uno menos cuatro por a porsche pero ese
es un 1 y 1 entonces me queda por menos
4 y todo esto dividido entre 2 por up
pero a eso entonces entre 2 y esto es
igual a menos uno más menos y uno menos
cuatro pues es menos tres entonces me
queda la raíz de menos tres
y todo esto dividido entre dos
y ahora voy a separar mi división es
decir voy a agarrar el primer sumando y
lo voy a dividir entre 2 es decir me
queda menos un medio más menos la raíz
de menos 3 pero la raíz de menos 3 es la
raíz de 3 que multiplica
es decir i veces la raíz de 3 y todo
esto dividido entre 2 bien ya tengo aquí
mi raíz ahora si ya tengo muy bien mi
parte real y mi parte imaginaria de ese
cuenta de que cuando yo separe mi
división se marcó mucho cuál es mi parte
real y cuál es mi parte imaginaria y
ahora sí si sustituimos en la ecuación
general voy a obtener mi solución
general de este problema particular
quién va a ser pues va a ser que igual a
él elevado a la parte real que en este
caso es menos un medio y voy a
multiplicarlo por x
y esta al menos un medio por x
multiplica a una primer constante que a
su vez multiplica al coseno de quien
pues observemos en la raíz quien está al
lado del número y que el número real
está multiplicando ahí y eso lo ponemos
aquí raíz de 3 entre 2 por x más otra
constante 2 que multiplica al seno de lo
mismo raíz de 3 entre 2 por equis bien
acá vamos a encontrar con un ejemplo
particular su solución general y es que
es muy fácil ya que tenemos toda esta
teoría que hemos construido
lo primero que se deben de aprender es
esta solución general que tenemos aquí y
dadas las raíces que también tenemos que
sacar nuestra solución ya es muy
sencilla de encontrar nos tenemos que
fijar en la parte real y en la parte
imaginaria la parte real es lambda y la
parte imaginaria es
con estos datos ya es muy fácil que en
cualquier examen nosotros podamos
encontrar esta solución general de hecho
en el otro vídeo voy a ver otro ejemplo
para reafirmar todo lo que hemos visto
así que no se preocupen y nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo cuídense mucho